bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
saison d'informations locales sur tv fil
78 7 8 le journal du lundi au vendredi
première édition en direct et voici les
titres de ce 1er septembre après une
dernière déclaration à la tribune lors
de l'université d'été du ps ce week-end
benoît - ancien ministre de l'éducation
a décidé de garder le silence il va
cependant siéger dans une semaine à
l'assemblée un poste de député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines occupé
jusque là par son suppléant jean
philippe mallet ce dernier est l'invité
du journal ils sont près de 500 nouveaux
professeurs des écoles stagiaires dans
le département à se préparer pour le
premier jour de classe demain mardi
parmi eux emmanuel de l'orne où nous
étions avec elle aujourd'hui dans
l'établissement marie noëlle à montigny
le bretonneux réforme territoriale
projet d'une nouvelle agglomération
allant jusqu'en mai sonne quel avenir
pour le département des yvelines pierre
bédier président du conseil général des
yvelines
réagissons une interview à suivre tout à
l'heure l'actualité aujourd'hui 1er
septembre c'est aussi cet homme qui
durant près de trente ans a exercé la
profession d'architecte sans jamais en
avoir eu le diplôme philippe leblanc
comparaissait devant la justice ce matin
le tribunal correctionnel de versailles
a rendu son jugement deux ans de prison
assortis d'un sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve et obligation d'indemniser les
parties civiles au nom du préjudice
moral
l'homme de 60 ans aperçu 926 1000 euros
de montant d'honoraires sur les quatre
dernières années
parmi ses réalisations situées
principalement sur la région de
mantes-la-jolie une polyclinique on
écoute les réactions des avocats à
l'issue du jugement au micro de yolaine
13 et 2 william l
vous savez que je suis surpris sur ce
qui concerne les souscripteurs qui ne
met pas vu leurs honoraires payés à
leblanc remboursé parce qu'à mon sens le
préjudice de l'escroquerie c'est les
honoraires versés indûment
et qui ont été déterminées par la fausse
qualité ce que j'observe simplement
c'est que sur les préjudices matériels
le tribunal n'a pas fait droit aux
demandes des parties civiles
et ça confirme ce que nous avons
toujours soutenu c'est à dire que
monsieur leblanc
certes construisez sans avoir
officiellement le diplôme et
construisent et bien je reçois pour ce
premier journal de cette nouvelle saison
sur tv fil 78 de jean philippe mallet
bonsoir bonsoir député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines en tout cas
jusqu'au 9 septembre date d'ouverture de
la nouvelle session parlementaire en
tant que suppléant vous allez donc
laissez votre place à benoît hamon qui a
quitté le gouvernement après avoir été
notamment vous le savez ministre de
l'éducation tout d'abord sur ce départ
vous qui partager les idées de benoît
hamon plutôt à gauche de la gauche
comment vous avez réagi à l'annoncé de
cette démission du gouvernement valser
au départ de benoît hamon
écoutez d'abord je serai députés tout le
mois de septembre pratiquement donc
jusqu'au d'une seule chose les choses à
mettre en place mais voilà tout à fait
la transition à faire écouter sur le
départ de benoît hamon l'a choisi de
benoît mans choisi de quitter le
gouvernement sur une raison de fond
c'est un peu logique est l'apanage des
hommes d'état le lorsqu'ils ne sont plus
en accord avec une ligne politique
proposé par le gouvernement auquel ils
appartiennent de partir et vous partagez
charles de gaulle l'a fait dans le passé
il n'a pas hésité à partir jean pierre
chevènement et là benoît hamon a fait ce
choix là c'est un choix noble choix de
courage quand on aime quand on n'est
plus d'accord
sans le crier trop fort mais on le dit
et on affirme sa position est bien sûr
que je la fasse cette position vous
partagez bien sûr que je partage cette
cette décision je la comprends il ya des
différences divergences qui sont nobles
qui ne sont pas des petites questions
qui traversent
je veux dire toute la gauche
on dirait c'est peut-être pas le le bon
moment alors que la gauche et pour
responsabilité qu'il y ait un débat
public mais la question
le vrai problème c'est que ces questions
quant à elle sentiments n'ont pas été
tranchés en tout cas avant que nous
arrivions responsabilité ceci dit
aujourd'hui le choix était plombée par
le président par françois hollande la
gauche du ps on va dire est plutôt mise
de côté on mise sur autre chose mais moi
je raisonne pas en terme de l gauche ou
pas les gauches sont des notions qui ne
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est l'état le niveau de service public
de protection sociale ce qui fait
profondément la nature de la france ou
alors aller vers une culture plus plus
libérale à l'anglo-saxonne je mets le
départ je pose le débat en ces termes le
être plus ou moins gauche est une
posture ou à à droite qui et
simplificatrice caricatural ce qui je
crois n'intéresse pas beaucoup les biens
des sensibilités
ça c'est bien sûr et social dit
lorsqu'on est électeur si on voit les
ruches on va savoir quel programme sera
mis en application à ce café comme
social-libéral un programme est alors je
vous pose la question on va inverser les
rôles
est ce que la politique menée
aujourd'hui par françois hollande et
celles qu'il l'a annoncé avant les
élections présidentielles en tout cas ce
n'est pas le sentiment que vous vous en
avez non vous avez le sentiment d'être
trahie en tant que socialiste aussi
trahissent et c'est c'est beaucoup dire
en tous les cas la musique que nous
entendons de la part de l'exécutif
aujourd'hui n'est pas tout à fait la
même que celle que nous a proposé le
président le président françois hollande
je m'enorgueillis de ne pas avoir voté
d'avoir fait partie de la minorité de
députés socialistes qui début octobre
2012 n'a pas voté le traité au budget
européen qui normalement aurait dû être
la mère de toutes les batailles
benoît hamon a décidé de garder le
silence après l'université d'été de la
rochelle qui vient de se terminer il a
tout de même déclaré ce week end que la
gauche n'a pas exploité suffisamment
toutes les marges de manoeuvre pour
réduire les inégalités il doit
s'inscrire dans quel courant justement
il doit s'il ya vote de confiance voté
la confiance au nouveau gouvernement est
ce qu'il doit marquer sa différence
rassemblé es les opposants écoutez il va
faire entendre sa différence qu'il a des
choses à dire
c'est ce que vous souhaitez votera oui
tout à fait sans être discourtois
désobligeants est trop trop critique
finalement vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
mais vous savez sur les 50 milliards par
exemple de réduction de la dépense
publique qui sont prévues programmés
dans les trois prochains exercices
budgétaires
c'est un débat qui agite y compris les
meilleurs économistes au meilleur niveau
sur les les vertus ou levi's d'une telle
d'une telle mesure
donc chacun chacun s'interroge il peut y
avoir des effets déflationnistes
attention à la contraction de la de la
dépense publique
l'investissement public et en
particulier investissements publics dans
les dents les collectivités locales
c'est un moteur puissant de l'économie
et du développement il faut un autre cap
pour gouvernement il nous semble mais de
toute façon exécutif maintenant à
affirmer des choses et a fait son choix
mais nous sommes un certain nombre
effectivement à dire que ces mesures on
va dire libéral c'est un mois un peu un
peu facile un peu valises
enfin ces mesures libérales on le voit
bien ne marche pas ne marche pas vous
n'étiez pas la recherche je vous ai posé
la question tout à l'heure un déçu de la
présidence mené par françois hollande
ces deux dernières années en tout cas
vous n'êtes pas allé à la rochelle non
je ne suis pas allé à la rochelle
je suis resté chez moi c'était trop
marquée travailler avec janvier votre
désapprobation nom signifie quelque
chose
non pas du tout pas du tout j'avais
envie de prendre un peu de recul un peu
de champ et puis de prendre le temps de
lire de travailler voilà benoît hamon il
va redevenir député vous conservez en
tout cas votre poste de conseiller
général dans le département des yvelines
mais que va apporter benoît hamon 7e 11e
circonscription mais aussi à la ville de
trappes où il siège en tant que
conseiller municipal
c'est notre question du jour tourner
aujourd'hui à trappes est elle en cours
on aimerait bien qu'ils veillent sur les
loyers et puis qui travaillent c'est ça
qu'on n'a pas vu sa puce au plus proche
du destin que que des régions en tant
que parent d'élève
c'est que par lui on puisse vraiment
être écoutés parce que j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on soit réellement
écouté
lorsqu'on a des requêtes donc pour les
enfants notamment avec la nouvelle loi
un peu plus de temps pour pour le
consacrer à nous
et on attend beaucoup de bac tu n'es pas
de paroles qui seul qui fasse bien son
boulot comme il l'a fait jusqu'à
maintenant fut tout à fait d'accord avec
ce qui est sa position avec son
expérience actuelle
il a plus une vue générale sur le pays
sur l'avancement de la france est donc
là il peut apporter attrape tout cette
richesse et cette expérience des actes
pas des paroles c'est ce que ce
qu'attendent les habitants de cette
circonscription les habitants de deux
trappes aussi pour benoît hamon qui va
redevenir député vous vous lui avait
passé ce message là ce que vous avez
déjà commencé à échanger avec lui aussi
pour parler des attentes dans cette
circonscription pour nous allons nous
rencontrer très prochainement moi je
voudrais d'abord dire que ça a été
être député avoir été député pendant
deux ans un immense honneur une fierté
j'en sais gré d'abord aux yvelinois qui
ont voté pour benoît moi-même initiative
mais également à benoît hamon de m'avoir
proposé d'être d'être son suppléant des
actes mais il y en a d'ores et déjà eu
des actes au service de
de la circonscription moi je rappelle
qu'avec guy malandain le maire de
trappes on a travaillé et on a obtenu la
décision c'était très importante et
benoît hamon au ministre il y avait pris
toute sa part d'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 ans est un vieux dossier
attrape auquel auquel tient
particulièrement le maire de trappes
donc ça c'est très important
il est arrivé d'intervenir dans
l'hémicycle également faveur de la
verrière vous savez tout l'aménagement
de la gare du quartier de la gare les
bécanes enfin des choses ont déjà été
faites et et benoît mois avec son son
son expérience son poids politique
effectivement apportera apportera
beaucoup mais voyez ce qu'exprime tous
nos concitoyens la danse qu'on a pu
entendre c'est vraiment c'est pas moins
ceux d'etats et moins de responsabilités
moins de présence de la puissance
publique au contraire ce sont des
politiques qui prennent leur
responsabilité moi ça me semble très
important
en tout cas ces opposants à benoît hamon
le pense fini terminé pour le
département valérie pécresse responsable
ump dans le département députés aussi
puis jean michel fourgous ancien député
de cette 11e circonscription battu
justement par votre tandem avec benoît
hamon lors du dernier scrutin nous
livrent leurs sentiments dans la
circonscription si vous faites la somme
des voix de son parti une chute de 60%
des voix bon ensuite on l'a vu
maintenant même dans sa propre ville
c'est le front national qui est arrivé
en tête aux européennes c'est pas le cas
de ma ville ayant dressage un bon c'est
pas la peine de se battre contre le
front national bien sûr tout est bon
ensuite il a fallu la caisse qui il est
perdu ou hainard si donc il est une
circonscription donc aujourd'hui comme
le disait d'ailleurs isner je crois que
le sénateur esneux
des yvelines socialiste qui dit que
monsieur hamon a perdu toute toute
influence dans le département je dire
qu'il a il aa
donc voilà un peu aujourd'hui en plus il
a été c'est le seul ministre sous la
vème république qui a été mise et les
questions nationales pendant quatre mois
pour la période des vacances scolaires
je n'ai pas eu l'impression que le fait
que benoît hamon soit ministre et
apporter quoi que ce soit de positif
spécialement au plan local mais je peux
évidemment en de ce point de vue ne me
tromper et ignorer certains de ses hauts
faits il va devoir faire des choix
effectivement en matière de mandat et il
faudra qu'il choisisse entre
effectivement la région et la casse qui
puisqu'il ne pourra pas cumuler tous ses
mandats donc ce sera un choix politique
important pour lui j'imagine
à votre avis la casse qui a région vous
savez déjà pour benoît hamon pour
répondre à valérie pécresse
non mais bon je vous savez je ne fais
pas de la politique comme ça je ne veux
pas polémiquer avec ses élus de l'ump
qui évidemment ont fait des merveilles
jusqu'à il ya deux ans alors qu'ils
étaient aux responsabilité
moi je constate que l'ancien député a
été battu à plusieurs reprises opposé de
députation est à chaque fois revenu ce
qui me permet d'ailleurs d'indiquer que
alors que j'étais député j'ai fait
partie d'un groupe qui a proposé le
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps quand on fait trois mandats de
maire ou de député ou le d'élus porte
déjà très bien et font savoir renouvelé
également mais les élus donc c'est un
message qui s'adresse j'imagine à jean
michel fourgous qui ne se représente pas
et éventuellement pour 2017 c'est votre
souhait problème autre sujet
l'université d'été non pas celle du ps
dont nous venons de parler tout à
l'heure mais celle du medef c'était la
semaine dernière dans les yvelines et à
jouy en josas manuel valls premier
ministre était invitée son intervention
a été très remarquée par les chefs
d'entreprise catherine le nato anthony
rech ont recueilli leurs impressions à
l'issue d'un discours marqué par cette
dorénavant célèbre déclaration qu'il a
prononcée j'aime l'entreprise l'avant
les applaudissements et même des chefs
d'entreprise debout à l'issue du
discours de manuel valls à l'université
d'été du medef le premier ministre s'est
fait ovationner une phrase aura retenu
l'attention sgm l'entreprise on est sans
doute en train de voir un tournant où le
gouvernement ou plus exactement le chef
de l'état qui a fait plein d'alliance
pour arriver au pouvoir est enfin
débarrassé d'alliance purement doctrinal
mais contre-productif pour la france et
dans ces cas là à nous effectivement de
savoir soutenir les actions si elles
sont dans l'intérêt de la nation
on est habitué aux discours politiques
qui sont toujours assurés qui se faisait
mais ruiné est plutôt rassurant c'est
quand même assez surprenant d'avoir une
standing-ovation dans ces quatre là
par exemple bon une chose est sûre c'est
que notre pays a besoin d'instruments
qui favorise le fonctionnement des
entreprises
je pense en particulier aux chances de
commerce qui ont été récemment
particulièrement chahutées nous espérons
que ce discours et les faits qu'ils vont
qui devraient les suivre et bien
permettront de rétablir je dirais un peu
plus cet équilibre est dans la fait
énormément
il y en a fait énormément on ne peut moi
je ne peux qu'être avides d'entendre ça
maintenant je dirais toujours avec
prudence des mots les mots sont le
langage le disco qu'on voulait entendre
maintenant des actes des actes il faut
les trouver du côté du pacte de
responsabilité défendu depuis le mois de
mars par le gouvernement car le client
ce n'est pas rien des engagements
importants conclus en baisse du travail
par bc travail parce qu'il ya un
problème du coût du travail des deux
pays suppression de la c3s belle de
l'impôt sur les sociétés ces engagements
seront mises en oeuvre
c'est nécessaire
nous avons applaudi au pacte de
responsabilité
nous avons applaudi aux rapports gallois
à la mise en place du séisme à la
simplification il ya toutes les mesures
des indications qu'il a aussi annoncé
donc donc tout ça est rassurant parce
que c'est du pragmatisme et de la
lucidité de la lucidité c'est également
ce qu'a demandé manuel valls ont chefs
d'entreprises en leur demandant
d'accélérer leur adhésion au pacte de
responsabilité pacte qui leur garantit
des baisses de charges une
simplification administrative en échange
d'un bon chez de négociations entre
branches professionnelles
on vous devez faire plus et plus vite
leur avis clairement le premier ministre
depuis mars
c'est énorme ça représente 9 millions de
salariés sur les 16 millions donc c'est
énorme
et en effet je crois que nous montons
une montagne progressivement avant l'
escalade le moment était à la détente
l'accord des entreprises gouvernement
semblait bien ancré à la fin de ce mois
d'août sur le campus de hec
j'enfile ma les invités de ce journal
socialiste lorsque vous entendrez ce
discours de manuel valls lorsque vous
voyez c'est cette ovation aussi des
chefs d'entreprise pour vous dis toi je
me dis que les entreprises sont
indispensables pour produire de la
richesse en france leurs marges ont
profondément diminué ça ne date pas de
la gauche au passage leurs majors
profondément diminué depuis
depuis des années ce n'est pas bien et
donc il ya un combat pour la
compétitivité des entreprises à mener
c'est indiscutable jeanne l'entreprise
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
il ya d'autres mesures derrière qu'est
ce que c'est sympa si l'animation un
merci d'un technocrate emmanuel macron
par exemple aussi pour moi c'est un
ensemble de choses
fallait il ya des entreprises dans
lesquelles chefs d'entreprise et
salariés sont sont épanouis travaille
bien
vous avez d'autres entreprises qui dans
lesquelles les salariés et même les
cadres les responsables d'entreprises ne
sont pas à l'aise ou d'autres qui
qu'ils peuvent je ne sais pas employé au
noir ne pas respecter la loi enfin
j'aime l'entreprise ça ne soit ça n'a
pas de sens moi je connais une réalité
si vous voulez en tant que co
responsables politiques c'est que quelle
que soit la taille de l'entreprise une
entreprise et fait du facteur capital et
facteur travail et il faut du capital il
faut des des personnes qui investissent
est très important mais moi je je je dis
qu'il faut aussi le facteur travail en
tant que je suis un militant de gauche
je défends la valeur travail et les
travailleurs et finalement ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce rapport de force
qui doit créer une dynamique entre les 2
1 mais j'aime l'entreprise quel est le
sens de tout cela c'est comme si je vous
disais j'aime les journalistes ou de
sciez tout à l'heure vouloir prendre un
peu de recul aussi ces derniers jours
par rapport à la situation actuelle vous
pourriez changer de formation politique
rejoindre un autre groupe vous y avez
pensé
pour l'instant nous attendons mais
l'apport l'instant il va y avoir une
réflexion qui va se mettre en place
effectivement au sein du parti
socialiste
ce que l'on vit depuis quand même deux
ans mais ça remonte à loin peut-être à
2005 rappelez-vous le référendum sur
l'europe c'est que quand même au sein du
parti socialiste
mais de la même façon au sein même de
l'ump
vous avez des des responsables qui
pensent des choses radicalement
différent différentes sur des sujets
très importants
effectivement peut-être que l'équipage
ne passe pas là où il devrait passer
donc il va y avoir une réflexion
politique collective qui va être menée
effectivement sein de la gauche et vous
concerne aussi personnel bien sûr jean
philippe mallet député suppléant de la
11e circonscription des yvelines invité
du journal ce soir aux était également
conseiller général des yvelines
l'interview qui va à suivre on va
changer de sujet va forcément vous
intéressez stéphane le foll le porte
parole du gouvernement a estimé qu'il ne
croyait pas en la disparition des
conseils généraux alors que vous le
savez sans doute cette disparition était
annoncée pour l'horizon 2020 ont de quoi
ravir le président de l'institution
yvelinoise pierre bédier que l'on écoute
au micro de catherine de l'atome j'ai
envie de dire tout ça pour ça je n'ai
jamais cru que les départements
disparaîtrait
j'ai essayé de faire de la pédagogie
pour expliquer parce que tout ça très
dangereux et très inconscient de la part
du gouvernement que d'avoir fait croire
que les élus ça sert à rien que ça coûte
de l'argent
qu'est ce qui plombe aujourd'hui des
départements tous les départements nous
sommes en situation financière
périlleuse
c'est pas nos dépenses d'administration
ce sont les dépenses sociales qu'on nous
fait faire le gouvernement matin midi et
soir invente de nouvelles dépenses
sociales parce qu'il faut dire que le
département finance puisque pour ces
deux personnages la france encore les
moyens de se payer un système de
protection sociale héritée du siècle
passé et qui ne correspond plus à une
recette c'est très dangereux ce qu'ont
voulu faire les socialistes et
heureusement qu'ils ne vont pas y
arriver parce qu'il peut pas dire
démocratie sans élu proche autrement on
sombre dans autre chose cet autre chose
je sais même pas ce que c'est je pense
qu'eux mêmes ne le savent pas et c'est
très très dangereux on ne traversera pas
la crise politique que traverse ce pays
on ne traversera pas cette crise si on
s'en prend aux élus dans ton conseil
général vous partagez cet avis faut pas
toucher aux départements n'ont aucune
réflexion ne doit être interdite
finalement là la vraie question c'est
comment rendre le meilleur service
public au meilleur coût aux français et
de cette réflexion vous en étant plutôt
favorable à une suppression écouter ce
qu'ils salaire de se dégager
les décisions ne sont pas prises par
l'exécutif c'est effectivement dans les
parties rural le conseil général est un
rôle important dans tous les cas le
conseil général un rôle de coordination
du travail des maires ruraux dans les
parties urbaines se sait plus
contestable et les conseils généraux ont
certainement moins de visibilité pour
l'instant dans les textes qui concerne
cette réforme territoriale les textes
qui vont être présentés prochainement
dans les prochains mois aucun ne fait
état de la disparition des conseils
généraux dans que soit le département
rural pas mais il ya d'autres points
très importants avec lesquels je suis
d'accord par exemple la suppression de
la clause de compétence générale pour
les collectivités territoriales
il y à un point sur lequel je serai
vigilant c'est qu'il avait été évoquée
éventuellement la possibilité de donner
une partie du pouvoir réglementaire aux
régions moi je ne suis pas favorable à
ça je suis partisan de l'unité de la
république
je pense que de dunkerque à bayonne avec
certes des petits aménagements mais
quand même la loi doit s'appliquer de la
même façon à tous le monde sinon ce
seront des disparités outre les quais
les noirs les plus riches et les plus
pauvres et ça je ne le veux pas sophie
que mal et merci d'être venus ce soir
sur le plateau conseiller général
adhésives line socialiste également
député en tout cas jusqu'à la fin du
mois de septembre s'est ensuite benoît
hamon qui retrouvera ce poste merci à
vous cloue si le journal se poursuit
aujourd'hui lundi veille de rentrée
scolaire nous avons suivi emmanuel c'est
une jeune professeur des écoles
stagiaire à montigny le bretonneux
demain alors a pour la première fois des
élèves devant l comment se
prépare-t-elle un reportage de claire
cambier de l'audi moines et là j'ai mis
des choses en plus et toi tu trouveras
du matériel en plus préparation du
matériel organisation de la classe pour
les professeurs des écoles la rentrée
scolaire a déjà commencé emmanuel de
l'orge et la nouvelle recrue dans cette
équipe de l'école marie noëlle à mon
team fraîchement diplômée elle entame à
23 ans sa carrière d'institutrice et le
stress commence à monter
ça commence à être concret donc langoat
comment ça un petit peu à monter mais
bon ça va bien tout expliqué j'ai un
petit peu rencontré le reste de l'équipe
donc je pense que ça ira
ce matin c'est plutôt un rangement puis
c'est plus tôt cet après midi qu'on fera
une réunion pour tout mettre en place
l'ag
institutrice aura cette année une classe
de cm2 dernier niveau avant d'intégrer
le collège un sacré enjeu mais elle peut
compter sur l'appui de la directrice
avec qui elle partagera les heures
d'enseignement c'est sa classe autant
que la mienne et on travaillera ben moi
je serai là pour l'aider elle a de la
chance c'est que pendant le temps où je
suis en décharge je suis dans l'école
donc toujours à sa disposition
et puis on a internet qui fonctionne
très bien aujourd'hui
en attendant de démarrer ce mi temps
emmanuel se prépare à accueillir ses
nouveaux élèves écrivent le président de
fait avait comme elle à près de 550
professeurs stagiaires rejoignent les
yvelines cette année pour les préparer
les informer des journées d'accueil ont
été organisées cet été comme ici à
villepreux pour emmanuel c'était
l'occasion d'en savoir plus sur sa
formation
car la moitié de la semaine elle
retournera sur les bancs de l'école à
l'école supérieure de professorat
l'éducation de quoi se perfectionner
merci l'analyse et pratique ce sera pour
nous histoire de dire un petit peu de
parler un petit peu notre expérience
comment ça se passe sur notre lieu de
travail
et sinon voilà c'est plutôt des cours de
didactique donc nous apprendrait
professeur comment faire une séquence ce
genre de choses un an de transition mis
étudiantes mie professeur qui dit
rentrée des classes dit forcément achats
de fournitures et les prix sont encore
en augmentation cette année selon
l'association familles de france
exemple pour un enfant entrant en
sixième il faut débourser en moyenne 189
euros une hausse de 2 17% par rapport à
autre enseignement de cette étude la
hausse des prix est cependant moins
forte dans les supermarchés que dans les
hypermarchés ou encore les magasins
spécialisés les clients y surveille donc
tout particulièrement les bonnes
affaires et ce dès le mois de juillet
écouter le responsable de ce magasin
c'est à la verrière le consommateur aime
bien prendre son temps pour choisir il
n'aime pas être bousculé et on conseille
on leur conseille de faire leurs achats
au fur et à mesure on leur présente les
essentiels
ils vont là dessus et puis après ils
vont ajuster en fonction des demandes
des écoles et suivant les besoins des
enfants
un mot de sport à présent de nautisme le
versaillais thomas barrau qui est devenu
vice-champion du monde de deux sans
barreur poids léger assisté du lyonnais
augustin mouterde c'est le meilleur
résultat du représentant yvelinois dans
une telle compétition lui qui défend les
couleurs du cercle nautique de
versailles nous l'avions suivi mais sur
ces images étaient l'an dernier après
son passage notamment aux jeux
olympiques de londres 7 8 le journal qui
revient demain mardi en direct à 18h
pour une nouvelle édition le replay les
rediffusions c'est bien sûr sur notre
site internet pour les reportages et
pour tout les interviews excellente
soirée et très bonne rentrée sur notre
antenne